hello and welcome to this little  announcement for what today's live shows  that are happening at the usual time  oh nice white slight changes that we are  streaming through twitch as well hope  well managing this technically speaking  anyway we've got the German show at 7:30  in the evening Central Europe in time  and then we've got this one they're  gonna show that it looks a little bit  different it's also on twitch yeah  anyway so we've got the English show  coming up at 9 in the evening Central  European Time so make sure to join the  easiest way to get down is to use the  links in the description to chests 24  which embeds the video and has one side  chat if you are premium on chest 24 can  also play me yeah thanks for watching